I'll get you Mario no man how am I gonna
win oh hello everyone I'm Bill Trenton
from Nintendo street house looks like he
caught me playing with my toys when I
was a kid I used to spend a lot of time
imagining who would win when my toys got
into a fight sometimes I still do but
wouldn't it be fun if you could actually
find out well pretty soon you can you
see while these may seem like regular
figures they actually hold a secret
within we're calling them amiibo and
we're going to create amiibo for a
variety of Nintendo characters games and
series starting later this year when you
touch these amiibo to the Wii U gamepad
controller you will see these characters
come to life in your games in many
different ways amiibo will expand the
gameplay experience of supporting titles
and bring about new types of fun and new
ways to interact with your favorite
Nintendo characters but since it's
probably difficult to imagine how amiibo
will expand your experience like to show
you so let me explain using the first of
many upcoming amiibo compatible games
super smash brothers for Wii U which
will release this holiday alongside the
first series of amiibo now when I talk
about figures and Smash Brothers fans of
the series will probably think of this
this was the opening video from super
smash brothers melee the original
concept behind this series is that
figures come to life and do battle all
on their own don't you wish you could
have figures like these
well that wish is about to come true
with amiibo let's say you head over to a
friend's house with a link figure in tow
your friend as a Wii Fit trainer figure
and luckily super smash brothers for Wii
U
each figure contains the spirit of the
character they represent so when you
touch an amiibo to the Wii U game peg
that character will appear in the game
to do battle while you cheer it on from
the sidelines just like the original
concept for the Smash Brothers series
there are many different ways to engage
these characters in battle you can pit
them against other figures you can face
off against them yourself they can team
up and fight alongside you and they may
even be able to beat up your friends for
you in the game of course every time
your amiibo battles its abilities will
get a small boost through battle they
can increase their overall level along
with their defense and attack powers it
can even learn tactics to become
stronger opponents in fact through
training they can become quite
formidable fighting against your amiibo
is going to be a lot more interesting
than fighting against a plain old cpu
opponent remember even if you and a
friend both by linked figures they won't
be the same you can customize their
special moves based on the characters
unique capabilities that means your link
amiibo becomes your personal version of
link that you can train and customize in
ways that make it different from your
friends version of link you get to
breathe new life into each figure as you
watch them evolve and witness their
personality takes shape this unique data
will be collected and stored inside each
amiibo in this way each amiibo is your
own unique figure that can act as your
alter-ego partner or rival just by
playing together plus if you battle your
amiibo against other amiibo they will
level up faster than against CPU or
human opponents collect your favorite
figures then battle train level up and
form your own unique bond with them who
knows your amiibo may even be able to
beat that one friend you never seem to
be able to take down on your own when we
launched super smash brothers for Wii U
this winter we plan to release several
Super Smash Brothers amiibo as well now
isn't this a sight to behold and there
are plans for even more characters on
the way so look forward to hearing more
and remember Super Smash Brothers isn't
the only game that will use amiibo we
also plan to make games like Mario Kart
8 Mario Party 10 captain toad treasure
tracker and Yoshi's wooly world
compatible with amiibo are you wondering
how each of those games will interact
with amiibo well each game is different
so look forward to hearing more about
them in the future
we have other plans for amiibo two more
games and figures are in the works as I
speak one more thing next year we plan
to release a peripheral that will make
it so you can use amiibo on Nintendo 3ds
to so look forward to Nintendo 3ds games
that take advantage of amiibo as well
combining amiibo with our games opens up
a whole range of potential new gameplay
experiences it's one of the most
exciting things Nintendo is debuting at
e3
stay tuned for future announcements
about amiibo and the games that will use
them thanks for watching
you
you